well this is a bit fancy I'm somewhere a
bit different today my uni has a
recording studio where they've recently
set up that's free for students to use
and so I thought I'd come in and try it
out it's probably a bit too serious for
the kind of casual video I filmed today
but I think it might be good in the
future I'm filming sort of educational
or more scientific videos so let me know
if you have any suggestions for the
things I could film in here one thing I
didn't expect to learn when I went to
uni was computer science at that time I
was only interested in theoretical
physics and astronomy but in my first
year I was enrolled in a computer
science course because it was
recommended for the astronomy major I
sort of showed up having no idea what to
expect I kind of thought we'd be doing
learning about hardware on what Iran is
how things actually work but I was sort
of surprised with what we actually did
learn which was a lot of variables and
types and how do you make functions and
how do you tell a computer how to do
something for you I kind of had a
love-hate relationship with this course
I liked it because unlike all the other
courses I was really learning something
new especially the first year physics
courses it almost felt like we were
rehashing basic ideas that we learned in
physics at school so we were doing
mechanics or electricity and magnetism
or a little bit of quantum and whilst
they were harder than school it was sort
of still the same ideas this computer
science though that I was introduced to
I'd really never learnt it before but
actually there were also reasons I
didn't enjoy this course in comparison
to my other courses it was the only one
where I really felt like I was behind
all of my peers instead of aiming for
the top of the class like I was trying
doing my other courses I felt like I was
struggling to keep up and I always had
to ask for help and I sort of felt a bit
uncomfortable with that at first when
some of my friends were discussing
coding projects they had done previously
in various languages I was still
thinking oh can you tell me again what
is a function but I got over that it
sort of got over myself and I did enjoy
the course
so much that eventually I took some more
computer science courses and learnt
things like algorithms or data
structures and how to write a more
effective code and I'm really glad I
took some of those further courses so
the first research project I ended up
doing in my degree I was working at an
observatory in Sydney and I was
essentially processing images of
galaxies to design a CubeSat
satellite and also a telescope I found
out that there wasn't really much
astronomy knowledge needed to do this
research project it was kind of an
exercise in coding my supervisor Phyllis
project actually had done his degree in
computer science and then specialized in
astronomy later on and I think that's
kind of a good way to do it actually
I think someone in astronomy with no
computer science knowledge would
actually really struggled because you'd
have to teach yourself coding as you go
and else you can probably do that it
might not be as efficient as a few new
some more of that background behind it
as for physics it really depends on the
kinds of things you want to specialize
in theoretical projects that involve a
lot of modeling or coding simulations
I think coding is of course going to be
a very important skill there and also
for experimental work if you're often
handling really large datasets you have
to know
to manipulate and keep track of that
data often through coding it is possible
to find projects within physics that
don't use a lot of coding if you really
want to stay away from it and personally
my project now doesn't actually use much
of that but it is really useful skill to
have especially if you want to automate
tasks on a computer and and make things
easier for yourself I also think that a
knowledge of coding or computer science
is going to help you not just in
research and with research projects but
going out into industry and your
employability later on a lot of
physicists end up working and storing
and manipulating data in roles such as a
software engineer working for big
companies so I think no matter what you
want to do it would be a really good
skill to supplement all of your physics
or your maths or astronomy course work
but courses I did were taught in the
language Python and that's what I've
used for all the research projects I've
done as well but there are lots of other
languages that are applicable to science
and you might also encounter some other
sort of coding software along the way
for example are for statistics MATLAB
for managing data and doing things with
linear algebra and matrices and also
Mathematica which is really good for
solving equations you probably encounter
some of these throughout your course
work and therefore solving the more
everyday problems learning how to use
these tools is more about learning
syntax and you can sort of get away with
not knowing some of the more theoretical
computer science aspects but it
certainly it doesn't hurt if you're not
yet at uni I really recommend you try
and learn some basic coding skills
there's lots of really awesome programs
that run now whether it's in schools or
outside
schools where you can learn the basics
of programming so that maybe when you
get to uni you don't feel as bewildered
as I festered
I thought sort of think it's a skill you
can pick up quite early on as well it
doesn't require a lot of background
knowledge to get started you don't need
to have really good math skills or
anything you can sort of learn the
language from quite a young age I think
and if you are already at uni maybe
majoring in physics I would say to try
and take as many computer science
courses as you can alongside your
studies I think they'll really help you
especially if you don't already have
sort of a self-taught prior knowledge in
the field keep an open mind as well if
you take maybe a couple of extra
computer science courses along the way
you might find you enjoy it more than
what you're initially intended to major
and that might be your new thing